si alors je voudrais vous demander la
permission deux journalistes américains
c'est pas du tout mon tempérament vous
mais je vous posais des questions
idiotes et puis vous me répondrez ce que
vous voudrez ajouté aux journalistes
américains mais en ayant votre
personnalité oui le chemin laisse un peu
de côté pendant quelques minutes on va
jouer c'est un jeu un ici chez nous cela
pas tellement d'importance
j'ai préparé des questions attention il
vous plait nous commençons et caméras
sont prêtes
line renaud êtes vous pour ou contre la
mode maxi en croire cette robe je serais
plutôt pour mais en réalité je préfère
la mini parce que je des cas à huawei
jeu je découvre très facilement mes
jambes chez moi y'a qu'la vous être
couvertes
[Applaudissements]
line renaud si vous surprenez votre mari
en train de s'amuser sur une plage avec
une jolie brune que diriez-vous que
l'américain soit je dirais rien parce
qu'à son âge je le vois mieux s'amuse
avec je ne vois pas s'amuse avec une
pelle un seau
[Rires]
nous sommes aux états unis tout le temps
line renaud en parle beaucoup d'érotisme
en ce moment qu'est ce que vous pensez
de cette vague d'érotisme l'érotisme
l'érotisme est à l'amour
ce que le poivre est à la bouillabaisse
un peu de poivre sa relève le goût trop
de poivre s'enlève le goût mais moi
j'aime la cuisine épicée d'une renault
êtes vous pour ou contre la pilule ni
pour ni contre mais je serais plutôt
pour ce qui vient après c'est pas fini
attention ils renault que pensez vous
d'une femme qui pour dîner en tête à
tête avec un homme met une robe en métal
qu'elle a envie qu'ils deviennent un peu
bricoleur après dîner
line vous aimez la télé la télé beaucoup
surtout quand j'y passe onduline que la
véritable amitié n'est pas possible
entre un homme et une femme
est ce que c'est votre avis absolument
pas la preuve c'est que presque tous les
hommes mariés ont une amie journaliste
américain oui parce que c'est vrai
alors disons que c'est vrai aux états
unis on s'en sort bien comme ça line
renaud
que pensez-vous du mariage quand on n'a
pas ce qu'on aime il faut aimer ce qu'on
a
et alors vous j'ai ce que j'ai mais
j'aime ce que j'ai donc j'y suis et ce
que je peux vous demander votre point de
vue sur l'amour ah oui l'amour c'est
très important
vraiment très important et comme tout ce
qui est très important il ne faut pas
leur mettre au lendemain quand on peut
le faire le jour même
viana avec sa guitare bon on en
reparlera
est ce que dans votre métier on peut
vraiment aimé son mari bien sûr on aime
bien le mari d autres pour qu'on
n'aimerait pas le sien
enfin dernière question à ce qu'un
artiste doit faire passer son métier
avant l'amour ou l'amour avant son
métier un artiste doit mettre beaucoup
d'amour dans son métier et jamais de
métier dans son amour à voilà une jolie
définition c'est tuer mais qui m'amène à
vous demander qu'est ce que devient le
jir loulo là dedans
à bas le loose de différent l'huile est
l'homme de ma vie à la ville comme à la
scène